er ist vielleicht nicht der liebste
feind des westens sicher aber der
dauerhafteste wladimir putin russlands
präsident für die einen ist er ein
gewählter diktator für die anderen der
retter der russischen nation
aber welchem bild entspricht putin
wirklich ich habe festgestellt dass man
putin vor allem außerhalb russlands aber
auch in russland selbst vermehrt als
karikatur war
die menschen sähen ihn durch eine
ideologische brille dieser ideologisch
gefärbten sicht will steven lee meyers
der langjährige korrespondent der new
york times in moskau seine version von
putins karriere entgegen setzen putin
der neue c heißt sein 700 seiten dicke
scopus dass putins aufstieg vom kleinen
geheimdienstagenten zum präsidenten
russlands schildert wenn man ihn nur als
diesen kgb ganoven sieht er es irgendwie
geschafft hat die macht an russlands
demokratisches experiment zu ergreifen
dann übersieht man wie er zu diesem job
kam nämlich ziemlich zufällig ein
präsident aus purem zufall
kaum ein bild beschreibt den beginn von
putins karriere so treffend wie diese
sequenz der damalige präsident boris
jelzin schlägt putin als seinen
nachfolger vor den schüchternen
verlegenen ehemaligen kgb-agenten der so
scheint es nicht recht weiß wie ihm
geschieht
manche glauben dass entweder gottes plan
oder der plan des kgb dahinter steckt
für mich war es aber eher eine reihe von
zufälligkeiten die dazu führten
darin zeigt sich das chaos der 19 90er
jahre das politische chaos dass jelzin
umgab der juristischen gesundheitlich
angeschlagen war
den hat der panik davor dass er einen
politischen wechsel nicht überlegen
würde am ende seiner präsidentschaft
unser nachfolger putin nutzt die
gelegenheit
er beschließt reformen gewährt jelzin
dem korruption vorgeworfen wird
straffreiheit
er stabilisiert die machtverhältnisse
und zeigt härte im tschetschenien
konflikt
er will das land wieder zu alter stärke
führen denn der niedergang der
sowjetunion hatte putin hautnah
miterlebt dresden 1989 putin arbeitet
hier als agent des sowjetischen
geheimdienstes kgb
er soll agenten anwerben für
spitzeldienste im westen im november
fällt die mauer
der sowjetische imperium zerbricht
überall werden geheimdienstzentralen
gestürmt auch in dresden
als die demonstranten zur kgb villa in
dresden kamen rief er den
militärkommandanten an verlangte hilfe
und verstärkung denn er war allein mit
vier anderen leicht hätte man das haus
stürmen kann
putin war alarmiert und dann dieser
unglaubliche moment der offizier am
anderen ende der leitung sagt nur er
hätte keine befehle moskau schweigt
dieses schweigen erschüttert putins
glauben an die mächtige sowjetunion als
deren kind er sich sieht er kennt die
erzählungen vom leid im zweiten
weltkrieg und vom großen sieg der roten
armee über deutschland als jugendlicher
sieht er den film schild und schwert
einen agentenfilm in dem ein
sowjetischer spionin die militärische
führung der nazis einträgt putin will
daraufhin geheimagent werden will dem
vaterland dienen und meldet sich
freiwillig beim kgb
schlüsselmomente einer biografie
steven lima es beschreibt wie aus dem
kleinen beamten putting der mächtige
präsident wird wie er sein netzwerk
aufbaut
seine gegner und die opposition
unterdrückt seine position nutzt um
reichtum anzuhäufen
einer der das instrumentarium der macht
zu spielen versteht
einer seiner berater der eng mit putin
all dessen image gefeilt hatte
beschrieben mir als 0
ich fand das verblüffend jemanden der
schon so lange so mächtig ist als null
zu bezeichnen
aber er meinte putin sei wie ein spiegel
oder eine projektionsfläche für die
hoffnungen der menschen
deshalb ist er so populär aber er
spiegelt auch die ängste viele haben
angst vor ihm
putins macht ist nicht die macht eines
diktators
aber die macht eines zaren in der
russischen variante von demokratie und
so bleibt er der liebste feind des
westens